IN A MOMENT, WE WILL HAVE THE
LATEST ON WHERE IT IS TONIGHT
AND HOW FAST IT IS MOVING.
BUT FIRST, THE NEWS OF THE DAY
WAS FOR THE MOST PART,
UNFORTUNATELY, POLITICAL.
OUR HAPLESS MEDIA TURNED OUT THE
USUAL DREARY MENU OF PALACE
INTRIGUES STORIES.
WHO IN THE WEST WING SUPPORTS A
SHUTDOWN?
WHO DOESN’T?
AS OF ANY OF THAT MATTERS OR
CARES OR EVEN REMEMBER THE NAMES
OF THESE PEOPLE TEN YEARS FROM
NOW.
WE WILL NOT, BECAUSE IN THE
SCHEME OF THINGS, THIS IS
IRRELEVANT.
IT MATTERS IS PROTECTING THE
COUNTRY.
SUDDENLY, EVERY POLITICIAN IN
AMERICA IS CLAIMING A MONOPOLY
ON THE BEST COURSE FOR WHERE TO
MUST DO THIS.
WHEN THEY SAY THAT, IT OUGHT TO
MAKE YOU NERVOUS.
IT CAN’T ALL BE RIGHT.
MOST OF THEM CAN BE
SELF-RIGHTEOUS, THOUGH, AND THEY
ARE.
HERE IS NEW YORK
GOVERNOR ANDREW CUOMO, WHO MOST
OF THE TIME HAS BEEN INCREDIBLE
ON THE SUBJECT, BUT TODAY
EXPLAINED THAT IF YOU DON’T
SUPPORT PRECISELY THE KIND OF
QUARANTINE HE SUPPORTS, YOU ARE
TRYING TO KILL HIS MOTHER.
>> MY MOTHER IS NOT EXPENDABLE.
AND YOUR MOTHER IS NOT
EXPENDABLE.
AND OUR BROTHERS AND SISTERS,
THEY ARE NOT EXPENDABLE.
AND WE ARE NOT GOING TO ACCEPT
THE PREMISE THAT HUMAN LIFE IS
DISPOSABLE.
>> Tucker: HUMAN LIFE IS NOT
DISPOSABLE, LECTURES THE MAN WHO
JUST SIGNED A LAW LEGALIZING
ABORTION UNTIL BIRTH.
ALL RIGHT.
TAKE A DEEP BREATH, GOVERNOR.
IN A MOMENT LIKE THIS, TALK LIKE
THAT, OVERSTATEMENT, HYPERBOLE,
IS NOT HELPFUL.
THE LAST THING WE NEED IS
ANOTHER DOSE OF MORAL BLACKMAIL
TO ADD TO THE LONG LIST.
WE WHAT WE NEED INSTEAD’S HONEST
THE PEOPLE ON TELEVISION ARE NOT
HELPING, MOST JUST BELIEVE WHAT
THEY ARE TOLD BY SOURCES
THEY THINK THEY AGREE WITH AND
THEN REPEAT IT TO US.
AT THIS POINT, THEY’RE NOT EVEN
ASKING THE MOST BASIC QUESTIONS
ON OUR BEHALF.
HERE IS THE MOST BASIC QUESTION
OF ALL, WHICH WE SHOULD ASK:
WHAT IS THE SHAPE OF THIS
EPIDEMIC?
THE TRUTH IS, WE DON’T REALLY
KNOW.
THE GOVERNMENT ISN’T DOING
LARGE-SCALE, RANDOMIZED TEST FOR
THE POPULATION, THANKS TO THE
SERIAL INCOMPETENCE OF OUR
HEALTH ESTABLISHMENT, WE STILL
DON’T HAVE ENOUGH TEST TO DO THA
THIS MEANS WE HAVE NO REAL IDEA
HOW MANY AMERICANS HAVE BEEN
INFECTED SO FAR.
THERE IS NO BASELINE FOR OUR
MEASUREMENT OF ANYTHING ACROSS
THE POPULATION OF 320 MILLION
PEOPLE.
WE CAN’T KNOW EXACTLY HOW EASILY
CORONAVIRUS SPREADS.
WE DON’T KNOW THE PHYSICAL
EFFECTS ON THE AVERAGE INFECTED
PERSON.
WE DON’T KNOW THE DEATH RATE.
FLAT IN THE CURVE?
WE ARE NOT SURE WHAT THE CURB
REALLY IS.
THAT IS NOT OUR OPINION, BY THE
WAY, IT IS ELEMENTARY SCIENCE.
AT THIS POINT, IT WOULD BE VERY
HELPFUL FOR PEOPLE TRYING TO
INFLUENCE POLICY TO ADMIT TO ALL
OF THIS, STRAIGHTFORWARDLY,
INSTEAD OF ATTENDING AT HIGH
VOLUME TO HAVE SOME CURE THAT
WILL ABSOLUTELY, POSITIVELY
WORK.
THEY DON’T KNOW THAT.
THEY CAN’T KNOW THAT, INFORMED
GUESSES ARE THE BEST THEY HAVE.
LET’S NOT LIE ABOUT IT YOU’RE
GOING BY THE WAY, THIS IS AN
ARGUMENT AGAINST QUARANTINES OR
SHUTDOWNS OR WHATEVER WE’RE
CALLING THEM, BUT IT IS A
REMINDER TO PROCEED WITH
HUMILITY AND HONESTY AT ALL
TIMES.
ONE THING WE DO KNOW AT THIS
POINT IS AMERICA WILL NOT BE THE
SAME AFTER THIS IS OVER.
SOME OF THE CHANGES WILL BE
POSITIVE, AND HOPEFULLY LASTING,
IF YOU FOUND YOURSELF CALLING
THE PEOPLE YOU LOVE MORE OFTEN
RECENTLY, YOU’VE HAD A TASTE OF
THAT.
BUT THERE ARE ALSO PROBLEMS TO
FIX.
A LOT OF PROBLEMS.
HERE ARE THREE WE WILL BE
FOLLOWING ON THIS SHOW, BECAUSE
AT THIS POINT, THEY SELECT THE
BIGGEST THREATS AMERICA IS
LIKELY TO FACE ONCE THIS VIRUS
PASSES.
THE FIRST OF THOSE IS A GLOBAL
DEPRESSION.
ALREADY, YOU ARE HEARING TWITTER
PUNDITS SCHOOLED ANYONE WHO
WORRIES ABOUT THE COUNTRY’S
ECONOMIC HEALTH.
AS IF THAT WERE THE SAME AS
CARRYING WATER FOR WALL STREET.
LIVES ARE WORTH MORE THAN SHARE
PRICES, THEY SCREAM, AND OF
COURSE, THEY ARE RIGHT, LIVES
ARE WORSE WORTH MORE THAN SHARE
PRICES, BUT IT’S NOT ABOUT SHARE
PRICES.
THE FINANCE MOGULS WILL BE --
NOT MUCH CHANGES FOR POOR
PEOPLE, EITHER.
BUT THE MIDDLE CLASS?
THE MIDDLE CLASS COULD BE WIPED
OUT BY WHAT WE ARE WATCHING
RIGHT NOW.
THE SERVICE INDUSTRY, MIDDLE
MANAGEMENT, SMALL BUSINESS, THE
INDEPENDENT CONTRACTORS, PEOPLE
LIKE THOSE MAKE THIS COUNTRY
WORK, AND MORE IMPORTANT, THEY
KEEP IT STABLE.
THEY ARE THE ONES IN DEEPEST
PERIL TONIGHT.
THE LAST TO GET TO THE MIDDLE
CLASS WOULD BE A TRAGEDY FOR
ANYONE.
YOU DON’T WANT TO LIVE IN AN
IMPOVERISHED COMPANY WITH A THIN
LAYER OF RICH PEOPLE AT THE TOP.
THAT’S A RECIPE FOR SUFFERING
AND FOR NEVER ENDING POLITICAL
SUDDENLY, FOR THE FIRST TIME
EVER, IT’S A POSSIBILITY HERE.
WE HAVE TO PREVENT THAT WERE OUR
GRANDCHILDREN WILL REGRET IT
DEEPLY.
CHINA ULTIMATELY IS RESPONSIBLE
FOR THIS VIRUS.
THE THREAT EXTENDS FAR BEYOND
THE CURRENT.
CHINA ALREADY IT’S ENTIRELY
POSSIBLE THAT WE COULD FIND
CHINA IN CHARGE.
NOW, WE’VE BEEN HEADED TO
DISASTERS OFTEN ACCELERATE
TRENDS THAT ARE ALREADY IN
PROGRESS.
EVERYTHING, INSTEAD, IN THE VERY
SAME WAY.
WHAT IS THE PLAN TO STOP CHINA
FROM TAKING ADVANTAGE OF THE
CHAOS THEY HAVE UNLEASHED AND WE
ARE SUFFERING THROUGH?
WE OUGHT TO HAVE A PLAN FOR
THAT.
WE NEED TO.
AND FINALLY, AS WE DO ALL HE CAN
TO FIGHT THIS PANDEMIC, WE
SHOULD MAKE SURE WE DON’T LOSE
THE MOST IMPORTANT PART OF OUR
BIRTHRIGHT AS AMERICANS, AND WE
KNOW THAT IS, IT IS THE RIGHT TO
THINK AND SAY WHAT WE BELIEVE IS
TRUE.
FREEDOM OF CONSCIENCE CONSCIENCE
UNDERVALUED, BUT IT UNDERPINS
EVERYTHING WE HAVE.
WHAT IS THE FOUNDATION OF A TREE
AND DECENT SOCIETY.
IT IS UNDER ATTACK BY
POLITICIANS, BUT MOST
DANGEROUSLY, IT IS UNDER ATTACK
BY MULTINATIONAL TECH
MONOPOLIES.
AT THIS VERY MOMENT, TWITTER HAS
DECIDED TO CONTROL WHAT YOU ARE
ALLOWED TO KNOW ABOUT THE
CORONAVIRUS.
OTHER TECH COMPANIES HAVE DONE
THE SAME.
TWITTER IS LEADING WHAT IT IS
CALLING "MISINFORMATION"
ABOUT THE PANDEMIC.
SOME OF AND ISN’T.
THE ACTUAL DATE IS A MOVING
TARGET.
THERE AREN’T MANY CERTAIN FACTS
ABOUT CORONAVIRUS, SO CENSORING
PEOPLE WHO SAY UNUSUAL THINGS
PROBABLY ISN’T GOING TO GET YOU
TO A SOLUTION OF WHAT THEY’RE
DOING ANYWAY.
AT THE SAME TIME, TWITTER LEAVES
CHINESE ESTATE PROPAGANDA
UNTOUCHED.
EVERY DAY, IF YOU’RE FOLLOWING,
A CHINESE GOVERNMENT
THAT’S TOTALLY UNTRUE.
BUT NONE OF THESE LIES HAVE BEEN
TAKEN DOWN BY TWITTER.
TWITTER IS BANNED IN CHINA, BUT
THEY ARE STILL DOING CHINA’S
BIDDING.
WHAT DOES THAT TELL YOU?
IT’S NOT A SMALL THING.
IT’S A TREND, A COLLUSION
BETWEEN BIG MULTINATIONALS AND
BEG AUTHORITARIAN GOVERNMENTS TO
MAKE YOU OBEY.